DEVILS BIT.
ARVIDSSON, STRONG SHIFT FOR L L
>> Steve: JACK HUGHES ON FOR HIS
FIRST SHIFT OF
THAULON.
WATCH HERE, HERE'S MOORE ON THE
SHIFT BEFO W ODD-MAN
RUSH FOR KINGS.
IAFALLO HAS A QUITE GET TO
IT.
JUST OUT OF HIS REACH.
AND
BROWN.
>> Steve: DAWSON MERCER GOT
LEVELED BY
TRYING TO ELUDE KOPITAR AND HAS
HELP.
NOW SEVERSON DEEP IN THE
COULD BE ARGUED THEIR
CAPTAIN OF TWO STANLEY CUP
MERCER TRYING TO S NTER.LEAGUE.
AND RYAN GRAVES DURING OUR
PREGAME INTERVIEW ALSO
REITERATED THAT THIS COULD
REALLY BE AIAFALLO CANCELED OUT
SEVERSON.
HERE COME THE DEVI BRATT,R A 2-.
RCER.
CAN'T DOWN ANY TIME.
THAT'S THE NEARLY TWO
YEARS AGO.
>> Ken: THE
OUTSIDE.
>> Steve:
IF YOU'RE WONDERING BY JON
GILLIES STARTING LAST NIGHT AND
TONIGHT.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME HE'S
AC
MOUTH.
BASTIAN PLAYING SO WELL SINCE
HIS ARRIVAL.
PLAYEDBETTER.
>> Steve: HUGHES SENDS ONE WIDE
OF
A NIGHT HIS WHOLE CAREER,
SOMETIMES MORE.
HERE'S THE DEVILS' SIEGENTHALER
A BLAST,
VIKTOR ARVIDSSON TO TIE THE GAME
SHOTS.
THIS TIME ARVIDSSON TO TIE THE
GAME.
DEVILS FAILED TO GET
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER OF THEATTAS
TO GRUNDSTROM.
IT LOOKE
WHITE WITH A SHOT.
>> Ken: RIGHT OFF THE THE NET.
AND THEN HISCHIER IS GOING